also hier war das paket war schnell hier
das ist mein iphone 7 plus sowie den
fachausschüssen überflüssig ist hey
leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut ich
muss mir erst mal entschuldigen
ich musste die alex videobild woche ja
leider wieder pausieren zwei tage ich
habe es einfach nicht hinbekommen weil
ich auch noch einiges für juni machen
muss alles hat zeige ich mich geklappt
sorry aber ist ja gar nicht so schlimm
ich habe nämlich eigentlich insgesamt
auf drei produkte die ich gerne
vorstellen möchte wir haben einen fake
iphone eine fake gopro und genauso so
zähne irgendwie auch wenn es jetzt auch
noch ich habe heute morgen mal eine
umfrage gemacht auf welches video ihren
als erstes bock hätte und da schaue ich
mal kurz rein und wir haben hier ganz
klar das fake iphone
dann würde ich sagen fangen wir damit
heute auch mal an die die jetzt lieber
die gopro gesehen hätten
tut mir leid gibt es aber auch mir wäre
das jetzt eigentlich egal gewesen so
bevor es losgeht aber wie immer ganz
ganz wichtig ihr könnt das produkt
gewinnen und ich lege wie bei jedem
anderen teil der alexijewitsch woche
auch noch einen 100 euro gutschein
obendrauf alle gewinner werden am 25
dezember bekanntgeben 100 teilzunehmen
schreibt einfach irgendein kommentar und
er müsste abonnent seien vom kanal
nachdem die automatisch teil in den
letzten tagen gab es auch schon einige
videos falls ich dir und euch gesehen
habt schaut euch die gerne an
da kann man auch überall was cooles
gewinnen und wir starten jetzt noch mit
dem produkt ich heute mache ich muss
sagen ich habe mich sehr gefreut und das
ist jetzt schon da es sollte eigentlich
erst zum 25
dezember an kommen deswegen habe ich
auch schon einmal reingeschaut einfach
weil ich mir unsicher war ob das das
jetzt wirklich ist was mir auch direkt
aufgefallen ist wir haben hier keine
typische wunsch verpackung also diese
normalerweise immer so grau wie wirklich
dann ganz normalen karton und ich bin
wirklich mal gespannt was denn heute bei
rumkommen ich habe ja auch früher schon
mal so schnell nichts getestet ich
glaube insgesamt zwei stück allerdings
war das meer so ein bisschen
oberflächlich und eine ahnung also dann
bin ich selber nicht so ganz zufrieden
waren wirklich schlechter ist deswegen
machen wir denn heute umso besser und ja
mal gespannt also leute wir schauen uns
das mal ein bisschen genauer an
dieses handy habe ich damals bestellt
vor ungefähr zwei wochen über
expressversand sogar
ich habe selbst wenn bestellt weil das
hier das anzeige bild ist und es halt so
ein bisschen aussieht wie das iphone ist
auch ganz klar hier zu erkennen dass es
sich halt um so ein iphone fake handeln
soll natürlich ist es am anfang ganz
ganz wichtig zu sagen das ist kein apple
gerät also das wird auch nicht mit der
ios betrieben sondern vermutlich mit
android steht hier auch genau dort halt
einfach nur so aussehen wie ein iphone
und ja das war's ich gehe auch stark
davon aus dass tag kein apple logo drauf
ist dann wirklich probleme geben
und das hier sind so ein paar bilder die
das ganze sehr hochwertig aussehen
lassen gerade hier mit diesem er ich
weiß nicht es ist schwierig zu erklären
aber wir kennen ja die maschen forisch
mittlerweile ich habe das meine ich in
schwarz bestellt genau hier
expressversand wir schauen uns erst mal
kurz die bewertungen haben 28
bewertungen insgesamt 3,5 sterne ich
glaube das ist das schlechteste bis
jetzt also das produkt mit der
schlechtesten bewertung aus der ganzen
woche so damit hier schreibt sehr schön
genau wie in der beschreibung bau hätte
ich mir so gar nicht vorgestellt oder
habe ich mir nicht gedacht dass das
anscheinend so gut funktioniert und
hätte sie ja nicht fünf sterne gegeben
so super wie es in der beschreibung
gelesen ist ist es nicht da ist kaum
empfang hat fünf meter vom router weg
keinen empfang mehr
diese recht scheint nun so wir haben wir
noch mal ein bild von dem weißen
exemplar der wir uns gar nicht gefallen
komischerweise haben wir hier nicht nur
deutsche rezension sohn aus der ganzen
welt irgendwie warum kann ich nicht
beantworten aber ist ja egal die werden
hier sogar auch mit casey die das heißt
man hält sein gesicht davor und das
iphone wird automatisch das iphone wird
automatisch gesperrt bin ich mal
gespannt ob das wirklich gigabyte ram 32
gb speicher ich mir jetzt auch kein
smartphone experte also mit diesen
technischen kenne ich mich ich will da
gar nicht ins detail gehen nach erzähle
ich irgendwas falsch es keine ahnung
also soviel bis hierhin eine sache die
ich noch kurz machen wollte und zwar
einfach mal auf amazon zu schauen ob man
da dieses handy kaufen kann und wenn ja
für wie viel geld eigentlich muss ja
irgendwann name stehen ich habe bis
jetzt nur den gefunden okay das sieht
dem in ich guck mal hier bei ebay kriegt
man das ganze sogar für 70 euro also die
spannung steigt wir packen das jetzt mal
aus ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei und
schreibt gerne mal jetzt eure
erwartungen in die kommentare
glaubt ihr ist wie gut oder glaubt ihr
wird schlecht also hier war das paket
war schnell hier das ist mein iphone 7
plus soli voraus an die die es nicht
wissen
überflüssig wir machen das ganze mal auf
hier haben wir direkt mal das ladekabel
und wir haben auch kopfhörer die
keineswegs so ausschauen wie echte ein
paar kopfhörer ich habe irgendwo schon
mal so ein unboxing von einem fake
iphone gesehen und da waren sogar
natürlich gefälschte das hat man auch
gesehen ich habe auch letztens ifec
airports getestet machen dieses schon
aber die uns immerhin versucht und hier
ist es ja überhaupt nicht so gut machen
wir weiter in eine menge schutzfolie für
das iphone damit natürlich auch nicht
kaputt geht das finde ich ja eigentlich
immer so das beste an diesen paketen
ich kann nicht den ganzen tag noch
auch hier haben wir den stecker wieder
ein mehr in meiner sammlung durch diese
ganzen bus bestellen ihr könnt euch
nicht vorstellen wie viele android
ladegeräte ich habe also diese ganz
normal locker über 10
so nochmal eingepackt also die haben
sich auf jeden fall mühe gegeben
ja das finde ich jetzt mal geil leute
guck mal hier ist sogar direkt dabei
damit sich ja die ist so etwas ein
gedreht aber das habe ich bis jetzt auch
noch nirgendwo gesehen dass man so eine
hülle direkt mitgeliefert bekommt finde
ich schon mal gut also dafür auf jeden
fall daumen nach oben lägen wir mal hin
jetzt kommen wir zum wichtigsten element
hier haben wir das handy jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt also finde ich schon mal ja
eigentlich sogar relativ ähnlich ich
zieh mal direkt diese folie habt
vielleicht haben wir da nämlich ein
iphone logo drunter das war jetzt echt
cool gewesen so sieht es von hinten aus
eigentlich sogar ganz stylish was das
jetzt hier soll keine ahnung design bei
designed by aid agencies dezember in
china wo auch sonst
also von hinten haben wir ganz sitzen
ähnlichkeiten mit dem iphone also einem
original iphone oder ein iphone 6 7 8
und hier kann ich jetzt beim besten
willen keine übereinstimmung erkennen
ihr vielleicht also
gut ist auch auf der anderen seite wird
ein bisschen fantasie vielleicht noch
hier oben der lautsprecher gut aber das
habe ich mir eigentlich schon gedacht
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was passiert
wenn wir es an machen ob man da dann
sagen kann ok wenigstens ist es so
programmiert oder das schaut so aus als
würde man ein iphone starten hier immer
das kabel der anschluss dafür ist sogar
oben und nicht unten so sagt als leders
auf sieht absolut gleich aus wir warten
einfach mal bis es angeht so sind gerade
aus also bis jetzt hält sich meine
begeisterung wirklich extrem in grenzen
ich weiß nicht wie es für euch ist aber
ich habe mir das schon ein bisschen ein
bisschen identischer vollgestellt 2000
jahre später leute kleines update
ich habe das jetzt seit 20 minuten am
strom das ist der screen denn hier eben
auch schon gesehen habt wenn man hier
jetzt drauf drückt steht da wo er kam
meinte und jetzt geht es aber wieder am
anfang dachte ich okay wahrscheinlich
ist einfach noch nicht genug aufgeladen
mittlerweile glaube ich dass da
irgendwas kaputt ist das halt irgendwie
der akku beschädigt ist keine ahnung ich
war natürlich noch ein bisschen ab aber
eigentlich kann es nicht sein dass es so
lange brauche man zu gehen ich habe
gerade heute wollte ich zeigt sich mal
kurz ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal das
ladekabel gewechselt das hier ist jetzt
das originale was bei dem handy dabei
war das geht ja gar nicht richtig rein
also versteht ihr kummer wir haben hier
mal das und dann haben wir das und das
geht ja wirklich rein mit dem kabel das
eigentlich gar nicht richtig dazugehört
lädt das handy und das kabel was
dazugehört funktioniert einfach nicht
vor allem das hat mich halt ich glaube
ich 77 euro koste 80 euro kostet es ja
gerade das ist jetzt schon über eine
halbe stunde dran das geht einfach nicht
das sind dann halt immer so sachen die
fakten richtig ab weil das video sollte
halt eigentlich heute komme und cool
sein so es ist jetzt auch das erste
produkt was ich bestellt habe was
einfach nicht geht also über die anderen
sachen haben halt alles funktioniert und
dann auch noch für 80 euro
weitere 20 minuten später ich denke der
akku ist kaputt sonst ihr könnt auch mal
gerne in die kommentare schreiben was
ihr gerade kaputt ist aber man sieht
hier auch gar nicht dass es also dieser
rote strich geht gar nicht weil
wenn ihr wisst was ich meine und das
kann ja so auch nicht sein ich meine das
geht jetzt schon 50 minuten ist
natürlich sehr schade vor allem auch für
das video hier
ich finde das dann auch immer blöd sowas
hochzuladen an die leute die sich jetzt
fragen warum das denn überhaupt höre ich
glaube das ist eigentlich auch ganz
wichtig so was war hochzuladen ich meine
ist ein beispiel dafür dass da
anscheinend doch nicht alles perfekt
läuft so wie es vielleicht in den
letzten durch videos von mir gewählt hat
diese woche das war auch alles wirklich
gut und hat mich überzeugt dass sie halt
so gar nicht und das ist halt ärgerlich
weil das waren 80 euro ich meine da kann
ich auch hier im laden gehen und mir für
80 euro das billigste handy kaufen ob
und wie ich das jetzt zurückschicke weiß
ich und ich könnte mir auch der
übertritt in die kommentare schreiben
sonst würde ich sagen nehmt gerne am
gewinnspiel teil und was ist also bis
hier mit dem videodaten kommentar und
abonniert den kanal an gewinnen
wenigstens einer hier den 100 euro
gutschein
ansonsten check die letzten videos ab da
gibt es dann das produkt auch noch mit
nach hause und wir sehen uns morgen
wieder da gibt es dann vermutlich die
gopro und das wird unsere cooles video
verspreche ich euch ich ärgere mich
trotzdem sehr
aber so ist das manchmal kann ich immer
alles perfekt laufen das war zu mir
haut rein